こんにちはー cd カープんです
相変わらずですね言葉の勉強まエイドの勉強について話したいと思います
今日はね今日のテーマはですね英語でね英語で
d やべえば d 2んの大きいですすなわち
いわゆるキハつく能力
注目する能力
について話したいんですあの言葉の勉強は3つの非常に大切な要素があるんですよ
一つは大漁勉強してる人の対応
勉強したい言葉が好き
絶対できる
今勉強している方法が
効果的ですとそれらの考えが重要なんですよ
それから第2話時間だから言葉はね早く勉強できるわけじゃないんですよね1月2月で
セブましたできるって言うもんじゃないんですよ
第3名はですね d 油 d 2
no ですその何がその言葉に起こっているかそれを気がつく
能力それが非常に大切
しかし説明するのは難しい
まず
一つの礼を申し上げます
外国人日本人だけじゃなくて外国人がですね
日本英語でワールド w 4 id
ウェイ
ショール sw を id 発音が違うんでしょ
同じ wod でもわー
ショーへそして w ははじめもしないですね
東4はワールドの場合はううそー
ファール聞きました
heard
ブー bi rd
だから同じうのその音にはですね色んな書き方があるんですよね
しかしうーん
スペイン人だとか者9人だとかですね
やはり ia birde ビール
うぇっ
お子様じゃなくて動いなぜかというとその発音がその書き方と違うんですよと
そりゃ気がつかつかあの気が付かないって言うわけですよ
そういう例が非常に多いですだから注意してね
実際には英語の書き方ですねあの均整がないんですよねそれを気が付かないとダメなん
ですよ
同じように例えばあの一度一瞬で言うと even あのよく
日本人がね even アイドンヘマーニー it ゴールドムービーズ
私はお金がないにしても映画を見に行きたいと実にその見るのが好きだと
しかしそういうフレーズが英語にないんです
even エフイービーンズ o
そりゃやはり注目しないといけません気がつかないものがですね覚えられないわけです
よ
でその道やて気がつくかとどうやってその能力気がつく
その注目する
その能力を
そのアップするかというとたくさん聞いてたくさん読んで
で大部分のその notice in というのは自然的に行われますしかし本人が
勉強している人が
やはり気がつくっていうか注目したいとある程度そういう意欲がないといけません
例えばじゃあ森林の中で黒蝶は歩くと言いましょうか
その同じ線路ですね歩いてもですね
この花にも注目しなかったとかこの綺麗なキーとかこの景色に注目しなければですね
同じ線路ずっと言ってもですね新しい
新しい知識というのはね集まらないんですよ
だからいいん私の場合はですね
その
勉強している時の最初までは割と簡単なストーリーをもう繰り返して繰り返して聴いて
いるときにですね
前階ですねあの新しいこの子の構造
あっこの言葉他でも聞きましたけど今度またもう一度
注目しましたとそういうふうにで
ですねあの意識的にその注目するんですよ
全部全部全部そうじゃないんですよ聞いている時に
サラーラ位の時に聴いてる時に時々こう他のことを考えますよね
けれども時々口は注目する9目数
注目数そういうその注目した
その部分がですね構造
発音あの発音一つの良い例ですよあの最初はねあまりはっきりと効かないんですよ発音
その
いろんなを
遠野市そのさあとかね少しずつこういうものにその意識的に注目すると気が付くとです
ね
少しずつ新しい集権に中間になってきますだから
そういう気が付くという能力がですねそれはやはりへ
が a その言葉を早く勉強する人
首都症でない人とその大きなさあだと思うんですよ
受け入れたい新しい言葉にその
女はねぇ開いて何が起こっているか知りたい
注目したい
醤油意識でですね聞いたり読んだりすると
少しずつこの新しい言葉
まあいるなる英語のいろんな近い方がいい
自分の脳らーその
巻がつくわけですよだからええ
その3つのですね言葉の勉強のやはり大事な要素ですね
やはり積極的な胎動
十分な時間それとその気が空く能力ですねそれはやや説明しにくいし
へそしてて多分大部分がその自然的にたくさん読んだりた草聞いたりすることによって
その我々がいろんなものを果たしものに注目しますけど
どもやはり発音にしても構造にしても合意にしてもある程度
意識的に注目してき月
携帯っていうかそういう意識で聞いたり読んだりするのはあるいははなし会をするとき
でも気が付くジャガード自分がなんかちょっと変な言い方しましたとか十分なその
あの自信がないとやはりこの部分自分のミスの時にも
中
木するそういう積極的な注目の
その
対応不がやはり平常に大切だと思います
じゃあそういうことでさよなら